foreign
how do we raise self-reliant kids
who have initiative who are resilient
and who could be problem solvers
kids who have the skills and the courage
to step outside of their comfort zone
and take advantage of what life has to
offer
I'm a mom to these three boys and if
you're a parent like me you've probably
asked yourself those very same questions
and while I'm sure that every caring
parent wants those same things for their
children
I think we're going about it the wrong
way
we want our kids to be happy and
successful
so our instinct is to Shield them from
hurt and disappointment
we worry about their self-esteem so we
praise them for everything
we we're concerned about whether or not
they fit in so we indulge them
and we don't want them to fail so we
step in and take over
and we do all of this in an attempt to
curate a perfect life for them
but what we're really doing
is raising kids who are afraid to take
risks because they fear failure
kids who lack the confidence in their
ability to figure things out
and then young people who are afraid to
launch into adulthood
more young adults are living at home and
for longer stretches
and this was occurring even before the
pandemic
a Pew research study found that 52
percent of young adults are living at
home which is the highest percentage
since the Great Depression
and what we're finding is that young
adults are stuck
between adolescents and adulthood
and that's the generation of people that
we're raising
and in fact we hear this in the language
that young adults even use when they
have to make responsible adult decisions
there's a term for it who knows what
that is
adulting yes the practice of behaving in
a characteristic of a responsible adult
so I am convinced that as parents and
caregivers we are missing out on a great
opportunity
to raise kids who are resilient and can
and can take hold of their future kids
who can step outside of their comfort
zone and do amazing things
now these are skills that are necessary
not only for them to lead fulfilling
lives and live out their potential
but those are skills that are also
necessary for our changing world
so back to my original question how do
we raise self-reliant kids who have
initiative are resilient and can be
problem solvers
I believe we do that by raising kids who
can think and act entrepreneurially
kids who have who have the opportunity
or have the skill set to view the world
from an entrepreneurial mindset
so let me tell you how I came to this
conclusion
so for more than 20 years my work was
centered around supporting adult
entrepreneurs
providing them with training and
technical assistance and resources to
help them start and grow their
businesses
and something I would observe we'd have
two individuals come into our office
seeking assistance and on the surface it
appeared that those individuals were at
the same level in terms of resources
capabilities skills and business acumen
but what we would find is that one
individual would take that information
and go with it
and then the other individual would just
seem to have trouble really getting
traction and getting going
and what I realized was that it had
nothing to do with skill or capability
what it came down to was the mindset of
that individual
in observing this got me thinking
how might I raise my children such that
they can view the world
like an entrepreneur
that they would have the courage to step
out and to change the world with an
entrepreneurial lens
so that set us out my husband and I on a
15-year journey to raise entrepreneurial
kids
and we really saw this come together
when my eldest son Silas was nine years
old
we have been living here in Maryland for
about two years and my husband was
planning to travel back to Colorado to
visit his mother and so Silas asked me
he said hey Mom can me and my brothers
also go with Dad to visit Grandma
and I said well you know Silas four
airline tickets were not in the budget
but
you can go if you can buy your own
ticket
so he paused for a moment and he said
okay
um well how much are airline tickets and
I said about three hundred dollars
and so his next question I have to say
it literally blew my mind
so he said
okay
um
can I find free stuff on Craigslist and
then resell it
yeah I was like uh yeah you can and so
then over the course of that summer
that's exactly what he did you know he
would get online and research Craigslist
my husband would take him to go pick up
those things and then I would help him
take pictures and post them online but
then he also did some other things that
summer he hustled so he he sold and
baked he baked and sold cookies and then
he also washed cars and threw out that
entire process my husband and I
we guided him along we were there to
coach and encourage him but we allowed
him to take the lead
when it was time for him to make his
sales pitch you know we coached him on
how to make the pitch but when it was
time to knock on the doors he stood
forward and we stepped back
and that summer he raised the money he
earned the money to purchase his airline
ticket and he made a little bit more and
he bought me a gift
but you know I'm I'm like I don't know
really who he was thinking about when he
bought that gift it was like me or him I
don't know
but
think about the confidence that this put
in him at nine years old that he could
have a big goal and that he could
persevere to achieve that goal
amazing
but when I share that story with other
parents many of them shake their head
and say you know what my kid could never
do that because my kids don't have the
entrepreneurial Gene
well being entrepreneurial is not
genetic
it is a set of behaviors that can be
learned when given the opportunity
entrepreneurs are not born
the skills and the experiences that
cause a person to be entrepreneurial can
be taught and it can be nurtured
now raising entrepreneurial kids is more
than just teaching them how to start a
business so they can earn money
raising entrepreneurial kids is really
about preparing Kids for Life
equipping them with everything that they
need with the confidence with the
ability to speak up to persevere to have
tenacity to bounce back
from fear and rejection those are the
things that are required in our world to
live to one's potential
so in order for me to learn as much as I
could about raising entrepreneurial kids
I interviewed dozens of parents and kids
to find out what they were doing
and so I want to share with you what I
learned
and I want to share with you five
strategies that I'm actually doing with
my children and that honestly I think
every parent should be doing with their
children to disrupt our conventional way
of parenting
so number one
don't give them an allowance
that's right that's what I'm talking
about too yes don't give them an
allowance instead challenge them to
start a business to earn their spending
money so this is my boys and this is how
one of the ways that they've earned
money their own spending money is they
make bracelets and there is no better
lesson around the value of a dollar than
when you have to work hard to earn each
one of them and through this process our
kids will learn confidence financial
literacy public speaking how to convince
people all skills that are valuable for
the world that we live in so don't give
them an allowance
the next thing is make them pay for
their wants
you know key to entrepreneurship is
about personal responsibility
and ownership
and it is amazing how when you put the
responsibility on someone else to buy
that thing that they said they really
want it
kind of shifts a little bit right it
really really does it's no different
with the kids
um and so we actually started this quite
early with our children so when Silas
was about four years old
I created daddy dollars
and the boys would earn daddy dollars
for doing things such as chores for
exhibiting positive behavior and for
also reading books and Silas actually
purchased his first
bike
from using daddy dollars he had to earn
250 daddy dollars and that allowed him
to purchase his first bike now yeah you
know these are not real real dollars but
to Silas that experience of working hard
to earn that money and to buy that bike
was a very real experience for him
also in 2019 our family decided to take
a trip to Tanzania
and so you know the boys were really
excited about it and I said now if you
want to go to Tanzania your dad and I
are going but if you want to go to
Tanzania you know what you got to do
what do you think I tell them
they're going to have to buy their own
airline ticket yes now the tickets to
Tanzania were not cheap they were 900 a
piece yeah
but check this out this is what I just
loved was when I told the boys that they
were going to have to buy their own
ticket Silas remembering back to what he
had done when he was about nine years
old he said to his brothers
[Music]
that's easy don't worry about it I'll
show you how to do it
yeah
and sure enough
they worked hard over several months and
they did just that
they were able to earn enough money by
selling their bracelets that I showed
you earlier and they all were able to go
with their parents
to Tanzania
so I would encourage you to make your
kids pay for the things that they say
they want
the next is to reduce their prosperity
now let's admit it kids today have a lot
of
stuff
right and when you think about it I
understand this need and this desire as
parents to want to give our kids
experiences and things that maybe we did
not have when we were children
but when we choose a parenting style of
over indulging our children
by providing them with too much
too soon for too long with no effort on
their part what we do is actually raise
young people who are self-centered and
entitled
and so when we instead
in the 1700s it's it's interesting
because Frederick Douglass made a
statement that I thought was profound
even in the 1700s because we're dealing
with it today and he said if you wish to
make your son helpless you need not
[ __ ] him with a bullet or a bludgeon
but simply Place him beyond the reach of
necessity and Surround him with luxury
and ease
still treated day
Steve Jobs in a speech to some grad to
graduate in a graduation speech told the
graduates to stay hungry
and what we love about entrepreneurs is
their hustle and oftentimes that hustle
is rooted in a hunger for something
but if our kids never want for anything
what's going to motivate them to take
action
so I encourage you to reduce your kids
prosperity
next is to let them be Delight directed
entrepreneurs are lifelong learners
they learn to do not simply to know
and when we encourage our children to
seek out learning for the things that
they are most interested in they become
Learners who seek to learn to do because
they're teaching themselves as opposed
to just simply pouring in information
which is sometimes what we get in our
education system
and so this is my my son Isaiah his
Delight is drawing and so he spends
hours drawing and he seeks out class
teach him how to draw and he was
recently
awarded
um an award by the Smithsonian Museum of
African art for creating thank you yeah
this superhero from looking at a piece
of art in the museum and he designed
this
but now Isaiah is designing logos for
people so now he's yeah I love it
so so give them room and space to follow
their Delights
and then lastly let them solve their own
problems
entrepreneurs are problem solvers
and as parents it is our natural
instinct to want to step in and help our
kids solve their problems
but when we do that all the time we kind
of squelch the potential that they have
to discover new things about themselves
new capabilities that they might have
it squelches their ability to go out and
find the answers for themselves
so I want you to think about those five
things as you begin to raise up young
people
and yeah you know what
it's very likely that my boys may not
choose business ownership when they grow
up
and that's okay
because rather whether a child chooses
to build a company or become an employee
it doesn't matter because every kid
needs to learn how to think like an
entrepreneur
and the sooner we do this as parents
create an environment at home where they
have the opportunity in multiple
occasions to challenge their beliefs
about what's possible within them to
step outside of their comfort zone to
take risks to learn from failure to
bounce back from rejection then the
sooner we'll put them on the path of
living out their potential to lead very
fulfilling and successful lives
thank you